say that nowhere in the Old Testament is
um speaking of the Messi a Nazarene uh
well if you go to Matthew 2:23 look it
up brother yeah yes this shows he can't
read the guy can't read Matthew 223
tovia singer says there's nowhere in the
Hebrew scripture says he's a
Nazarene okay read Matthew 223 and he
came and dwelt in a city called Nazareth
that it might be fulfill fulfilled which
was spoken by the prophets he shall be
called a Nazarene now I want you to pay
attention to the formula and I want
everyone to listen because you got to
learn this argument in Matthew
2:23 Matthew says the
prophets predicted Messiah would be a
Nazarene here's my challenge to every
one of you I want you to start reading
from Matthew 1-2 whenever Matthew quotes
an actual prophecy
he says this was to fulfill what the
Lord had spoken through the prophet
singular he doesn't use prophets plural
did you notice here he says prophets
plural yes so right there if you're
paying attention carefully he's not
referring to any specific prophecy of a
prophet he's saying this was F to
fulfill what the prophets said he shall
be called a Nazarene now unless Matthew
thinks thinks that you have several
prophets all saying he shall be called
the nazarine that shows that tovia
singer can't
read you caught
it yes it's not an actual prophecy in
those words otherwise Matthew would be
implying more than one Prophet said
those words he'll be a
Nazarene he's telling you that the
prophets have in general mentioned the
fact that Jesus is a Nazarene now does
Matthew mean the word Nazarene appears
there or does Matthew mean that the
prophet spoke of the Messiah who is
Jesus in such a way that we shouldn't be
surprised that he ends up being
associated with
Nazareth as a Nazarene why because the
prophets talked about the Messiah being
humble and humiliated
right yes is
52 and other passages that talk about
him being humble humiliated debased
rejected condemned scorn Psalm 22 Daniel
9 right the word Nazarene isn't
referring to an actual prophecy where
several prophets use the word nazarin
the word nazarin is associated with the
Messiah being humbled humiliated debased
rejected accursed condemned and that
that is stated in Psalm 22 I'm a worm
and not a man Isaiah 52 beaten Beyond
human semblance and the the Israelites
considered him a cursed of God Smitten
by God condemned by God Daniel 9 Messiah
cut off humiliated but not for himself
so on and so forth how do I know
Nazarene is meant to
convey messiah's humiliation because
Nazareth was cons was
viewed by zealous Jews as a place of ill
repute as less than ideal place to live
in how do I know go to John 145 and
46 I'm losing my voice guys so pray for
me John 145
146 Philip found Nathaniel and said to
him we have found him of whom Moses in
the law and also the prophets wrote
Jesus of Nazareth the son of Joseph and
Nathan nathanel said to him can anything
good come out of Nazareth now you see
why he's called
Nazarene because he comes from a place
that even the Jews look down upon in
scorn as the less than ideal State for
the Messiah to come out of Messiah would
come out of such a
place so even his dwelling in Nazareth
fulfills the prophecy that says Messiah
would be humiliated would be
abased would be humble would be lowly
and wouldn't have anything that would
attract people to him so he's not called
nazarin as an actual name mentioned in
the prophecies Nazarene is being used in
a derogatory sense meaning of all places
that he came forth he comes out of that
one place that even the Jews look down
upon as an indication of what the
prophets say he would be humble lowly
humiliated abased and
debased making sense or no yes so my
challenge to the idiot toia singer is
can you show me when Matthew is
appealing to an actual prophecy he uses
the word prophets plural as opposed to
Prophet
singular he doesn't when he's talking
about a prophecy he says this is what
was spoken by the Lord through the pro
here don't take my word for it go to
Matthew 122 read
it uh so all this was done that it might
be fulfilled which was spoken by the
Lord through the prophet saying singular
is it
prophets no okay and then he quotes
Isaiah 7:14 now go to Matthew
25 and was there until the death of
Herod that it might be fulfilled which
was spoken by the Lord through the
prophet saying out of Egypt my soning
Prophet right yes now continue from 16
all the way to
20 then Herod when he saw that he was
deceived by the wise men was exceedingly
angry and he sent forth and put to death
all the male children who were in
Bethlehem and in all its districts from
two years old and under according to the
time which he had determined from the
wise men then was fulfill what was
spoken by Jeremiah the prophet
singular so saying now if you had read
all the way up then Matthew expects you
now to notice the difference in 23 Now
read 23
read I the rest of it or no no just read
23 because you caught it Jeremiah the
prophet the Prophet The Prophet singular
right yes now notice the difference in
23 and he came and dwelt in a city
called Nazareth that it might be
fulfilled which was spoken by the
prophets now why did he change plural
because he's not referring to any
specific Prophecy with that name you
caught it now yes you saw what Nathaniel
said about Nazareth can anything good
come out of it in other words Nazarene
signified that the Messiah wouldn't come
in the glory of a king he would come
humble lowly abased debased humiliated
which is why of all places he comes out
of Nazareth the very place that the Jews
look down upon with
disgust so he's telling you that the
prophets essentially prophesied that
Messiah would be of such lowly status
humble status that he would actually
choose to come out of a place that was
looked down
upon a place that wasn't
viewed as being a place you would expect
the king of glory to come out of
Nazareth so Nazarene signified Messiah
being humble and lowly of no
reputation it had nothing to do with the
actual word appearing in the
prophets do you think Matthew really
meant that more than one Prophet used
the word Nazarene of course
not making sense or yes making sense
making sense is it sinking in I don't
want to move on until it sinks
in making sense you got it or you still
a little confused no I got it you see
prophets do you really expect m you to
believe more than one Prophet said
Nazarene no so he's telling you that the
overall gist of the prophetic message is
that Messiah would be lowly humble
humbled humiliated debased and abased
and that's signified by the fact he
comes out of Nazareth a place that was
looked down upon that was considered to
be of no use especially for the Messiah
to come out
of that's it yes I got it so thank the
Lord Jus but toia singer he's a demon
like Ali their fathers the same Satan
unless and until they repent